you've met the Queen of England yeah
now all I know about meeting the Queen I
have not met her but I do know that
there a lot of rules when you meet the
Queen about how you would dress her I
don't think you're allowed to touch her
they're an incredible list of things
that you need to follow as you follow
those rules I did until I had a bottle
of red wine okay and then it went
completely pear-shaped right and it was
her birthday and we had to perform it
was a rule variety each year you you get
asked to perform for the Queen so I done
a little song from macavity and cat's
aunt called Mankowski and uh anyway we
all line up afterwards and I'd been
upstairs without and John and Ida that
some of his $1,600 a bottle red wine and
it made me a bit wheezy I think it might
have been off I don't know
yeah the second bottle was definitely
off or a member and the third bottle
we're a bottle was invisible
yeah you drank a lot and then you met
the Queen what did you do well it's
customary it's like an old joke really
that the Queen or the you know the queen
or princess died when we played FA Cup
as Princess Diana but you know there's
always two royalty and they have the
best sinks in the house at Wembley
hundred thousand people's like Super
Bowl they sit there and as we're all
lined up she came along and for some
stupid reason I asked her if she needed
her Cup final tickets yeah you asked her
for her a friend of mine a friend of
mines a scalper uh-huh so you asked the
Queen of England if you could have her
tickets your scalp yeah
and what did she do well it was funny
because she was like that and she looked
at her aid like that and I step forward
to shake hands like that and she moved
away in a way right and she walked away
from you she she I so did everyone else
right
the Lauren sort dispersed where she had
smashed you over the head with a bottle
there was there was only wine bottles
there sooo big no Budweiser bottles
there no
we can win the Queen
you